- [Instructor] What we're gonna talk about
in this video is how various
political ideologies can affect
folks' views on economics,
and when we're talking about
economics and government policy
around economics, there's
two fundamental types.
There's fiscal policy,
which we will focus
mainly on in this video,
which is the idea of how
much does the government tax,
and how much does the government spend,
and this is fundamentally in
control of the U.S. Congress.
Then you also have monetary policy,
and these are ideas around interest rates
and the money supply in service
of keeping the economy strong
without having inflation run amok,
and this is controlled
in the United States
by the US Federal Reserve System.
Now if you were to put the
various ideologies on a spectrum,
it might look something like this,
and I put liberal ideology on the left
because it's often associated
with a left leaning ideology,
and I put conservatives and on the right
because it's often described
as a right leaning ideology.
Libertarians are interesting
because, if we're talking
about economics, they
have a lot more in common
with conservatives than
they do with liberals,
but if we were talking
about social issues,
it would be the other way around.
Libertarians would have
a lot more in common
with liberals than
conservatives on social issues.
In general, Libertarians want
less government intervention
on either dimension, on
economics or social issues,
but now let's focus on
the entire spectrum.
So if we were to think about liberals,
what's your sense of how a
liberal might think about,
say, fiscal policy, taxation,
and government spending?
General speaking, liberals
favor a larger government,
and this larger government
happens through higher taxes,
higher taxes,
and higher government spending
and more government programs.
Higher spending,
and the reason why they tend
to favor a larger government is
they will invoke ideas
of a safety net that
in a wealthy society everyone
should be provided for
on some level.
They might invoke ideas of fairness.
They also believe that a
larger government is out there
to protect the citizenry from
being taken advantage of,
and so they'll also favor more regulation.
Now conservatives would
take the opposite stance.
They tend to favor smaller government,
smaller government,
and it would be in the
form of lower taxes,
lower taxes,
lower spending,
and less government regulation,
less regulation,
and they'll make the
argument that the less
that the government
gets in the way the more
that the economy can actually thrive.
The more that business can do well,
the more competitive our country will be,
in which case everyone will be better off,
and so they're often associated
as being pro-business,
but many conservatives would argue
that by being pro-business
it's actually helping more individuals.
Now an idea that often gets associated
with liberals is one
of Keynesian economics.
Now John Maynard Keynes was an
early 20th-century economist
who argued that a government
could use fiscal policy
in order to stimulate the economy.
So Keynes argued that
during recessions the government
could even run deficits
in order to stimulate the economy,
that even deficits were
not bad, by lowering taxes,
because lower taxes would put
more money in individuals'
and business' pockets,
and increasing spending.
So higher government spending.
Higher government spending.
Now although Keynes is most associated
with a liberal ideology,
especially because it was practiced
during the depression
by FDR, some would argue
that it might have come
out of the depression,
it turns out that most mainstream liberals
and conservatives do practice some form
of Keynesian economics.
Liberals tend to stress the
higher government spending.
If we're in a recession, the
government should spend more
to stimulate the economy to put
more money in folks' pockets
so that there's more consumer spending,
which could drive the economy.
Conservatives try to
favor the lower taxes.
You will see conservative
government officials say,
"Hey, we want to lower taxes
to stimulate the economy."
Fundamentally, that is a
Keynesian point of view.
They're focusing on the
lower taxes angle of it.
In either case,
if you're spending is
higher than your taxes,
both sides would run a deficit
in order to stimulate the economy.
Sometimes the conservatives are associated
with the idea of supply-side economics,
and this is the idea,
this goes back to being
pro-business and even lower taxes,
that, hey, if more people have
more money in their pockets,
especially those who invest or those
who are starting businesses
or businesses themselves,
that they can then expand their capacity.
They could go and hire more people
and that this would be good for everyone.
Now what about libertarians?
Well, on economic policy,
you could view them
as even more conservative
than conservatives.
They would favor the
smallest possible government.
Smallest smallest possible
possible government.
Many libertarians would argue
that the government should only be there
to protect property rights,
to have a common self-defense,
to have some basic public
safety, and outside of that,
the government should get out of the way,
and people would be best off,
and many libertarians would even argue
that the whole idea of
a Federal Reserve System
that's actively controlling
monetary policy is a bad idea.
So I'll leave you there.
This gives you a big picture
of how political ideology connects
to folks' views on economics.